ready the results of tonight's election
i Neal Jack acting returning officer for
the Blackwell North and Cleveland
constituency declare that the total
number of votes for each candidate is as
follows close Susan Jane commonly known
as su Liberal Democrat 747 votes Maynard
Paul Christopher conservative party
candidate
twenty thousand two hundred and fifty
five votes royal Duncan John the Green
Party 381 votes web Christopher Paul
commonly known as Chris Labour Party
eighteen thousand two hundred and thirty
two votes white bull Martin UK
Independence Party
you kept one thousand three hundred and
ninety two votes the rejected ballot
papers are as follows did not bear the
official mark zero voting for more than
one candidate fifteen writing or mark by
which they kept the voter could be
identified two unmarked or void for
uncertainty 42 I declare that poor
Christopher Maynard is duly elected as
the Member of Parliament the Blackpool
north and clearly constituency
[Applause]
Thank You Neil it's a pleasure to be
reelected for a third time to represent
the people of Blackpool north and cleave
leaves and to receive more vote that
I've ever received before in a general
election can I thank all the counters
and all the people who've organized
tonight's count for expediting the
process she's always a tense and
difficult process and they've done an
exceptional job tonight and I'm very
grateful I thank the police the
presiding officers all the polling
station Clark's have done so much over
the course of the day not just to ensure
that the election runs well but to keep
us all safe and secure in these
uncertain times can I rededicated to
work on behalf of the people of block
for Norton tea please and for the good
of the country in the years to come we
do not know what the outcome of
tonight's election will be but I know
for certain that our continued represent
every single constituent in Blackpool
north and peevly's no matter who they
voted for tonight